how many of you guys do deep learning
not one okay good so this is it's going
to be interesting so the first slide I
always like to do with AI is the new
electricity right this is a quote from
Andrew ng many of you know who is he and
it's a new way of thinking how how all
the application that we know today eyes
are gonna change and there is going to
be this new algorithmic way of executing
task we have seen the driving cars going
around while 10 years ago you will never
really think that will happen ok ok so I
had the pleasure to meet him a couple
weeks ago at the Stanford he gave a talk
about the deep learning and what's the
future so why why deep learning what's
what's new about this the first thing is
we have a linear improvement with the
amount of data what does it mean he drew
this this graph that I try to reproduce
and so you can see with traditional a
grid you get to some point where even
adding more data does not help the
performance of the algorithm we are
bound to some extent but with this new
deep learning model it seems that even
adding more data they can just improve
and more more data improves the final
performance of the algorithm since there
is no really an upper bound so far and
that's what this driving a lot of the
excitement because of this of this
factor and the second point I want to
make about deep learning why is so
exciting is the model scalability before
once you have one of the salary you are
you can only play with the parameter
of how you training you can really
modify it you can really augment it what
we deep learning you can you find new
building blocks and you can start stack
them as Lego blocks and these Lego
blocks can create new blocks and you
start stacking on one on top of it in
the last year we have found so many ways
of doing this and it's being a very
exciting time so a little example I want
to do is this playground that tensorflow
has made just to have an idea of how how
powerful these things can be and it's
pretty fun so we we want to to fit this
data where you have two classes you can
see you in the color orange and blue and
so right now we can't really fit it
because only we we have not enough
what's called capacity in our neural
network but we as as we start to improve
our model by putting more neurons and
more hidden layers you will see that the
system starts to to to have more better
ideas and more power to classify these
these points so it's very empirical in
some sense but you see that eventually
it will start converging to to the right
to the right shape
and so what we create now where every
time I had a hidden layer I had a new a
new block it's creating a new algorithm
okay and and this is is this is very
very powerful there is this compulsion
compose your come when you can compose
blocks together okay and we'll keep
going don't remember the exact
configuration of the for the neural
network to make this work so you is
really empirical you you can you can fly
around and you can see some of the known
models that work for for well known
problems and so one of the the most
recent innovations is we are able to
train these convolutional neural
networks and so the normal neural
networks are just liars of matrix
multiplication where each each node is
fully connected to the liar before okay
when you have think this is just as an
array when you have this configuration
is pretty easy but when for images this
becomes very expensive to compute the
whole matrix multiplication so what what
what we do instead is taking a small
window called a filter and which we
slide over the original image and we do
that fully connected the procedure of
summing and multiplication only on that
filter and we create as you see in this
example you have an image of 32 by 32
and three channels usually RGB this
bach blue boxes the computed features
out of the image and that inner the
block is the computers feature so you
multiply that same initial block
multiple time with different weights so
you have different representation of the
initial image and if you if you break it
apart you see the feast the first one is
the image the fifth column and then the
second is the filter and the and the
third the second and third of the two
filters and then that the last column is
the output of this of this procedure and
you have to think this about overall the
image of our older the sly so it's a lot
of computation and this is the reason of
the race of necessity of using gpus
because GPUs do this very fast my 20
times faster than than CPUs and the
numbers always diverge based on who you
talk with intel and nvidia so we are we
have this power of compulsion composite
bility and you can imagine there has
been a lot of empirical work of okay how
do we compose these to make performance
better and the the fact that you want to
be able to compose this makes the need
of having a tool like the new frameworks
that coming up of be able to compose
these stacks in different ways but still
be able to then train it and we train
today with a back-propagation and
granted in st. and the procedure is to
compute the gradient between one layer
and the play and the previous one and
before the in the last years before the
last year's they you will have to do it
manually and it's tedious work very rare
prone but now with new frameworks like
tensorflow you are able to compute
and specify only the forward part of
your network and they will be able to do
inference of what is the gradient
computation that you need for those
operations and so playing with this
neural network has become much much
easier and a lot of adoption is is
currently going on so we can explore one
of the most successful one is for image
classification and we can see image
classification statistic of how far we
got in the india curacy this is a top
one accuracy ad means you give an image
to the today algorithm they're going to
give you exactly what is the class of
that image and as you see we are with
the latest one this inception resnet
vtune this came out a couple of a couple
of weeks ago we already are about 80% we
have also top five accuracy and hear the
results are even even better with the
the inception resonate going 95.3 and
it's estimated that the human accuracy
of a trained men is below 95 around 94
and so this is all this excitement also
for for this reason but let's keep
talking why again a deep learning is we
have to do less featured engineering
okay I think we know grad in the
gradient boosting you really need to
manipulate the data in the right place
to actually be able to fit it properly
okay you need to do some fishin
engineering while in the example that we
saw with the narrow networks you just
give data it has to be normalized just
so the numeric part of it is a stable
but you don't really need to do too many
image too many featuring manipulation
and that's because never met
are able to to learn the most useful
features and so the question raised
prices of how to see this self learn
feature looked like oh hey we have an
image as an input we have these matrix
multiplications what what does have a
feature for an image look like and
before all the the field of computer
vision will have handmade filters or
kernels that had some magic numbers
inside it that will be able to detect
patterns most common ones where the
gabber filters but incredible enough
these neural networks are able to to
find by themselves with this training
procedure these filters by themselves
okay and these are the typical the
interesting part of this is dessert the
features that are only at the first
level so the second level of another
network uses the feature of the first
level to compose and create new features
at the at the second level until you get
high level feature of what is a car what
is a bus and i wanted to show a little a
little video here of these researchers i
think they are in in berkeley that is a
nice demo that show that some of these
disappearance inside that the inside the
neural network those weights that we saw
before some of the neurons like in this
case is able to speak to to find the
vertical lines you see the total energy
of the of the cell is max when there is
a vertical line inside the image know if
you guys can see the is right in the
middle while although the neurons are
basically zero mean the black means that
is zero as our activation function and
white means is close to 1 and
this is our other example is a very
interesting video that shows all this
feature this feature is able to detect
face it just activates when he sees a
face inside the the image this other one
activates when he sees two phases so it
starts it starts by finding these these
features these signals inside the the
data that you provide it and so to train
these images classification whenever
later you really need a lot of of images
because the pattern arise over thousand
a thousand of the images and and before
II we were not able to compute even all
this amount of information and so now
the question is okay we are able to use
and create this this feature what can we
do can we use it back in the in the in
the previous work right they this what
does it mean learning a feature okay so
there is this very very interesting
concept of out encoders and so what's
the idea here the idea is we have a
neural network that it will absorb some
data and we have lawyers that will
shrink at some point at the beginning
you have let's say you as an example you
have 100 never never answer you have 50
and then you'd go down to 10 neurons but
then you expand the network again where
you go from 10 back to 50 back to 100
and you want to say to the to the neural
network you have to minimize the
difference between the input and the
output okay and the input output are the
same image and so what this thing does
is compressing it finds some
configuration of the neural network in
the middle that is able to represent
this information
and this is is used extensively in LP
today and it's called wort whack well
you get the words and you compress it in
a vector of space and this what this
space looked like and I have a little
interactive galaxy where all the images
are compressed and you have a
representation of your world I think
this there is another processing step of
mapping it is called TS knee that maps
it to a 2d so you can be displayed but
the inner the inner feature out are
computed with a neural network ok one of
my favorite code is yeah talk is cheap
show me the code and so I have a little
a little demo that the shows that shows
how to do this with the neural networks
and what we do here this is a HR and we
are connecting to what is what is my
cluster that is in a in California and
we are going to use what we have is an
auto encoder estimator and the data set
that I use is the olivetti image
classification and so what I do with
this is beside the data managing and try
to read the data from the image format
down to array we have a zero to one gray
scale image as an input and we create a
data frame with all the images so all
the rows I take the image i unroll it so
it's just an array ok and for each row
is an image ok so we have this big table
with each row an image of this face and
what I say today to the encoder please
encode this this pace of all the images
what's a representation of all the
images of human faces the size of the
image is a 112 by 92 so this is a demo
just just to play around correct this
this is our implementation of the out
encoder and it's just Java base and is
already in production so you can
download it and play with this yourself
you don't need GPUs because of the sides
of this neural network and there are
nice things about that you don't need
always a neural network right if your
problem is little no need to have GPUs
and all of that and with this example we
are able to encode all these images we
just give to the narrow network ok
what's what's the representation of of
all these images of all these faces and
then to understand to understand what's
this hidden space of values we feed in
noise and this is what we get out ok and
it's a remembrance of of the faces of of
that category so is very interesting of
how is is able to to do these totally
unsupervised I didn't say to the
algorithm anyway that those are faces
well as a human are able to see these as
a as a face ok and so one application
that is it's being used of of the old
world and the new word is okay can we
just create new features to add to the
old features and we get the better model
all together and this is a technique
that Google had a nice post about it and
shows how you have wide and deep models
wear with the wide are they all the
future base feature engineer the
approach but then you have this new
additional features that are coming from
the south encoding
I'll grid okay so this is how do we put
this algorithm in production okay
because we want to get these features we
get all these night algorithmic doesn't
end with with that image we want to put
in a server we want to have a an API or
sometimes just a report of what's what's
the best thing to do and with a cha we
are trying to create a nice framework
for doing deep learning and so the idea
is not everyone is going to be able to
have gps on their machine but most
likely and big company you have a server
dedicated to it and the idea thanks to a
cho you can send the python code over a
REST API so your code on your machine is
very lightweight but the computation all
happens on the on the on the data
cluster and what we are leveraging to to
do this big computation on now on
thousand of images bigger images so you
need the GPUs for the reason that we
talked before and there are very nice
frameworks and we integrate we are
integrating with them the fifth one is a
MX net tensorflow and cafe and so what
you do is you connect to a virtual
cluster you ingest all the data from
from spark then you execute this data
over frameworks like tensorflow and MX
net without leaving the Huo context and
so you have the ability to to model
using tins of law you want to ability to
use MX net or cafe because each one of
this framework have some sweet spot for
the typical for some of the of the
problems but the nice thing is then you
don't have to to put in production each
one of these frameworks you just use H
overall and just worried about the model
all the engineering part of deploying it
and putting API and making sure the
model is different is all in the same
pipeline you just need to worry about
the model make sure that the the
expertise you have is on the on the
problem that you're trying to solve not
on engineering problems we solve those
for you and so the example that we saw
it was a cho deep learning CP only Java
distributed and deep water is the new
product that is able to use and leverage
this new framework and as I was
mentioning you get all the deep learning
framework with the batteries included
okay if you ever try to install
tensorflow MX night you have to compile
C++ you need to have the libraries it's
doable but it will get a few days of
your time to get it right well you can
start implementing all grades and so all
the all the things that you want and you
need to get to production like ipod
parameter optimization cross-validation
hyperparameters search early stopping
all this thing that you need when you
are creating Dawson of models at a time
especially with we if you have a big
data science team each one is using the
class that you want to have some process
on having a good pipeline of taking out
models and some of them some of the
neural networks are very empirical so
you can get lost trying to build your
own we provide pre-built models of the
one of those that are known to be good
so the image net models are pre
pre-baked pre-tested they just work you
just need to invoke of course talk is
cheap it showed me the code and so what
I want to show you here is we have an
extensive library of examples on our
website so you can download the
notebooks just played around but i want
to show in specific alone
so this is another tiny problem as I see
410 come how to classify it in images
and in this and this problem we are also
they're loading the images having
unrolling all the batch and creating a
new data frame inside the Huo and as you
see these are some example of the images
that 32 by 32 image we initialize our
HTO cluster we create our data frame of
tests and unlabeled notice that we do
not do not send the data from python 2h
whoa we just say where is the image
because then the actual class can
paralyzed that fetching of information
imagine if its URLs it will just grab
everything in parallel as mining class
you have and the bandwidth of your data
center and create this big data memory
block that then is able to feed very
fastly to GPU because the GPU now is
faster than fetching your data before
with big data you have to wait for the
disc to to load but not right now not
the GPU is so fast that you have to feed
it properly and so what we have here is
a natural deep water estimator where we
only have to specify this network name
and this network is a one of the famous
image classification Network a few years
old right now but but just specifying
that the name the system then we load in
the background all the neural network
pre-built and run it over the cluster
and so you have different values of this
network as of today you have a Lynette
Alex net v DG resnet inception Google
net but a nice thing about that is you
can do a grid search over which one of
those algorithmic
do for your specific problem for your
specific dad yes pre built by us already
back Dean that the system just does a
lookup unload yes no just the neural
network just the architecture yes yes
and this is these are famously those are
published so we know that they work yes
we still train on your dad yeah
otherwise otherwise we'll try to find
the classes on on the on off ah no but
you can do that you can train and the
idea is initialized in as this neural
network as random state with some with
some properties but then if you have a
neutral state that is better than a
random state you can utilize that there
are some constraints like the now the
number of weights has to be more or less
the same as a number of layers and you
have to do some matching when you do
transfer transfer learning but if the
input image is the same and the number
of classes as an output is the same you
can do you can do something like that
but of course this is a bit of a
limitation of having just pre bike
models but indeed what you can do is you
are able to insert your own your own
image you are owning image algorithm and
this is an example of using amex net so
this is the state of the art of image
classification as of today and this from
google the inception resonate with you
as you see is a very very deep network
all of those are liars okay you have ten
layers of this fifth configuration 20
layers of the second ten layers of the
and it takes like a week to train over
millions of images what Google did is
after the Train it just gives the
weights out and you can load these
weights and start retraining on your
specific that's this is exciting
transfer learning what I want to show
here is how you can use amex net this is
the amex net Python library ok so
untouched download it from from the
repository and we build using that
library they graph representation of our
neural network so we compose using
Python you see all the layers ok this is
a convolution network then contain you
can really play around and build the
neural network and then simply you can
then this is a loading of the of the
data then you can simple allocate by the
number of classes that you need and then
save it as a representation so the input
is just a JSON file and if we look at
this JSON file
so I'm just taking out the first line 10
lines of the of the file it's just jason
i just specify what are the nodes what
are the inputs is just an amex net
specification and what we do here is
then import that exit file inside the
Deepwater estimator okay and this this
loads all day all day all the network
layers inside the GPU and then we
continue with our actual process of
checkpointing imaging and all of the
engineering work that you need to test
your your model and so what you will be
doing is back and forth from this cell
where is your network down to to execute
so ideally what I want you two guys to
do is you just need to press run
subsequent cell and you modify the
network and run it again and this is
will connect to the 20 h whoa will take
care of running it as a job on
everything and then we have other other
tools down the line where okay well over
over a week you can do this back and
forth but over multiple months you need
to have a system that compares how this
new model compares to the to the one
that is in production I don't know how
much time do we have things about to to
wrap up so I wanted to show you a little
bit of the code that we have for for
doing all that the tuning of a parameter
research this is this example online
shows on the on the deep learning part
so we build we build our our model but
then then we want to start inspecting it
and you have the confusion matrix here
we want to to test if actually predicts
the right thing we want to maybe have a
variable importance okay what which one
of all the variables that we create it
is the most important one and this is
something that we pre computed already
okay so you don't have to you can go on
right again but this is repetitive work
you should not be doing that and this is
another nice feature of the issue of
framework is you can just do grid search
on the hybrid parameter and remember is
everything distributed okay psych it
does it on your machine but we do it
over the cluster so you're not bounded
by where you're running it and so from a
nice console you just launched multiple
multiple jobs you can put is this h/o
deploying a choo is copying this jar
file on a machine and then you do java
dash jar and the and the denote will
will come up and yes you can spin up an
AWS instance with tons of gigabyte of
ram and cpu spinning up have a VPN
always good and then connect from your
laptop to that machine and start sending
python code and your ear code you can do
the the saving of the code on your
machine because this the python api just
sends api call okay so it's a nice
framework to work with and then you just
need to specify for example here the
hyper parameter that you want to do the
grid search on this is we specify in
this example I think this is a bit I
just realized so these are the okay try
with this configuration of hidden layer
this is a fully connected neural network
so everything is the fee simple example
that we did and so the system will do a
cartesian search for each combination of
the first parameter it will do a
combination of the second
okay so this one with this one this one
with this one this one with this one
over and over and of course this for a
small set that you want to do to
optimize is good enough but sometimes a
most of the case you need what's called
random grid search where you just
specify okay well this this is the range
of valid l1 parameters okay just do a
random search over all the space and
specify how much what's the maximum time
that you want to wait ok so you second
in these five minutes give me the best
you can find as an argument doing a
random search of this hyper parameter
and of course this this is you can
launch multiple processes it depends on
your on your resources and on the back
end and the last point is you have model
checkpoints so if you're running this
for a week at some point things can
happen on the AWS itself can fail what
what the this system does is a check
pointing it will save the complete state
of your of your search and your model in
a in a serialized format and then you
can reload in a second time you can shut
down the AWS copy you copy first the
data shutdown AWS next days you copy
over the data and reload and this is is
all it's all built in it's all ready to
use without writing additional code and
do through the engineering process of
doing all these steps okay so last
announcement we are doing an open tour
in dallas where we going to show more
demos more hands-on approach on how to
use h1 and if you want guys want to meet
there I have a promo code HOA year get a
nice discount and a on that event if you
guys want to learn more and
have more documentation and code it's
all online this is completely open
source by the way is you you download it
you hack it you can change it ready and
so this that's it 40 minutes sharp thank
you any question do you guys use deep
learning on any little bit yeah so state
of the art of NLP it uses deep learning
anything or even the famous NLP
professor Stein for the one of his poop
pills is create a company and it's also
sell force and they were NLP doing deep
learning so it's something to look at it
and play with it the tools now are
amazing it's very easy and fun to to
play around so the idea is we use Python
is very good to manipulate now you have
this money ability of code and and ateh
but we tend to flow what we do is we get
this power and we create out a
computational flow graph and this what
we were I was showing here okay so with
Python you just specify how does this
look like and once you have this
representation usually a JSON file like
we saw order like another format you can
send it to some execution engine in this
case in our case in the actual execution
engine we read the graph we understand
what are the operation and we execute it
and so you have you have this division
between the representation of what needs
to be done and who is going to do it and
so with this thing is a bit it's a bit
more involved doing the
the specification you don't use the
structure of the language itself now
when you do x + y you're using the tree
of the language to understand what's the
computation you have to specify add x 22
why but then you have this nice property
that you can then execute in other in
other environments and so we tensorflow
you will import tensorflow create your
own graph and then you export as a you
do a save and your expert as a protocol
buffer is the format of tens of law and
then you specify that protocol buffer to
Huo Huo is able to reconstruct the graph
use tensorflow for the for the GPU
operations and once that cycle is is
complete it returns the accuracy all
those parameters that then we compute
and is continuous with the usual
pipeline and of course we package
tensorflow we make sure this is working
you don't have to install it that's so
that's always good to have this
integration work is it takes a lot of
time yeah yes that's completely
independent so when you when you when
you create the graph you can specify ok
I want to have access also to tensile
board and it will it will write the data
to some directory you have to be a bit
aware of what you're writing those files
but then you can launch tensor board on
top of that one thing that I forgot to
show you guys that is very interesting
is we have something very similar to the
tensor board this this is a common
control of the heo cluster where you can
show ok give me all the models that
being trained give me all the jobs that
are running and then for it for the
model you can you can explore what's
this what's the status what's the score
in history and one thing that we do
compared to tensor board this this is a
real-time update so as your training you
will see how this is updating but yes
that's that's the thing is you you are
free to do normal tensor Florida max net
operation and then when you really want
to to put in the production pipeline and
you need access to the remote class that
are not everyone can accent to the
cluster then you just serialize it as a
protocol and put it as a job queue and
it would be processed let's see thank
you